the first death in the nation's growing
e.coli outbreak is raising new concerns
about the source of the contaminated
lettuce blamed for the infections one
person died in California the outbreak
has now hit half of the country with
people sick in 25 states there have been
nearly two dozen new cases since last
Friday
Jericka Duncan is following the story
with the latest jurika good morning good
morning the only thing that Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention has told
us about this e.coli death is that the
person lived in California and they're
warning remains the same do not eat or
buy romaine lettuce from the Yuma
Arizona growing region it's been more
than a month since the first reported
case of e.coli from contaminated romaine
and the CDC still has no answer as to
exactly where it started or how long the
outbreak will last initial reports last
month showed that 17 people were
infected in seven states since that time
those numbers have steadily increased
now up to 121 people in 25 states from
coast-to-coast doctors say there's a
reason this particularly coli strain is
making so many people ill normally you
have to ingest tens of thousands of
bacteria to actually get sick with this
organism ten to twenty to a hundred will
get you sick even though yuma arizona's
romaine lettuce growing season ended
about a month ago the number of cases is
increasing because of lag time and
reporting and because people might still
be eating contaminated lettuce symptoms
which might not show up for three or
four days include stomach cramps
diarrhea and vomiting it's very scary
not knowing what's what's gonna happen
next
Destinee Jarboe seven-year-old daughter
Mikayla was recently hospitalized after
eating lettuce at a Mesa Arizona
restaurant I didn't realize how serious
it was you know like no one has ever
told me that ecoli is life-threatening
at least 52 people have been
hospitalized including 14 people with
kidney failure the CDC has not found the
source of the infected lettuce and one
agricultural expert told us there could
be more than one source which may lead
to multiple outbreaks at the same time
Anthony Jericka thanks